[Applause]
[Music]
we are back and Michael bé is here with
us which I like to say in my b um he's
got a new whiskey out called brazer and
Thompson music and whiskey they often go
together everybody uh but maybe nowhere
more often than at the legendary Whiskey
A go- Go Club on Sunset Boulevard in
Hollywood so in honor of Michael's
whiskey in honor of you it's time for a
game called whiskey whis a goo how much
do you no
no whiskey a
goo how much do you
know that is the worst greatest thing
ever I I love my writers I'm look I'm
looking or did y'all write that is that
all y'all you're like we not claiming it
all right I'm looking for for Lord I'm
looking for you to help us out can
you
well I certainly can Kelly and happy New
Year to you and also to you my bé my
bé all right now here's what's happening
in this game I'm going to give you a
clue for a musician or a band and your
hint is that this musician or band once
performed at the whiskey Agogo okay but
there's a Twist if you hit your button
and you answer incorrectly you got to
drink some of bublé's whiskey mhm we
also got some non-alcoholic drinks out
there too if you want always drink
responsibly okay Kelly and Michael you
each playing to win a big prize for your
side of the audience I can't remember
what the prize is okay that's right
that's right I can't remember what the
prize is cuz I'm hammered already but if
you lose if you lose you're going to get
eaten alive by polar bears so here we go
here's your first question that would
suck thank you God you're welcome I
haven't eaten yet I'm nervous oh this
going to be fun then we going to have a
good time I hope you get them all wrong
here we
go these guys were actually the house
band at the whiskey before they went out
as Riders on the Storm to find Michael
that is the doors I believe it is the
doors you don't have
to what you don't have to drink does he
cuz he got it right right I have to
drink right but I thought I won
something
yeah okay just one more
everybody who made that but I won what
is this we are a great it's whiskey but
it's mixed with something it's mixed
with Miracles um everybody's a winner
everybody's a winner drink up drink up
buttercup here's your next question okay
this Orange County band gave listeners
absolute certainty that the front lady
was more than just I knew it was going
to be her okay no doubt no doubt no
doubt I'll drink some to you too go
ahead and have a CL what was what was
the clue how did you know that she they
said Orange County ban female lead come
on I'm going to take a sip too okay okay
here is your next question that is
smooth man I can read it this pair of
British Brothers once said they were
bigger than Beatles Michael Oasis it is
oasis yes I feel like they would say we
are bigger than the Beatles I feel like
they would say that oh fine have a sip
go ahead take a shot why not I'm sipping
responsibly I haven't eaten like I think
you should have a chardet bé charday bé
chard I like that bé charday from Mars
drink the day away with Gourmet bé okay
here's your next
question come on now come on
now pretty good here we go question
number four this British brand started
with four Dudes before adding a woman
named Stevie to the m oh Fleetwood Mac
it is Fleetwood
Mac you got it
Kelly and we got ourselves a
tithe that noise means that we have time
for one more question oh and are we tied
that we are tied Michael that's correct
so this one is worth double because I'm
seeing double so here we go okay here we
go this British Piano Man played at the
whiskey early in Kelly Elton John it is
Elton
John
and youve done it the whis run out Kelly
is the
winner she said really good she said she
was going to kick my butt I did she said
I'm going to kick your butt and she did
I only speak truth I am not joking when
I say this is really good thank you I
wouldn't have brought it up again and
again it's really good um but if you
come to my show everyone's a winner so
everyone
this is a great GI for all of you who
like to write like Michael and myself uh
the moleskin notebook is inspired by the
legendary notebooks used by artists and
thinkers over the past two centuries mol
skins collections include the New Year's
artist collection I love New York and
python planners oo I like python
planners to Unleash Your human genius
y'all you're all going home with a $300
mle skin gift
card thank you Lord for joining us today
again and Michael's whiskey is called
frer and Thompson and it's delicious
it's available online and it selects
Spirit
[Music]
[Applause]
retailers thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home